[Music]
good morning everybody it's
seven o'clock here in the uk you're very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
right here at sky news dare to dream
could football be coming home england's
certainly making all the right moves
after last night's big win against
germany we're live at wembley and are
talking to fans and former football
stars throughout today's show to find
out
what their fortunes might hold as we
head to rome
plus we're talking covid and coal power
with the climate change minister
anne-marie trevelyan
shortly and making new memories we're
joined by the
england legend david seaman to reflect
on last night's big win
putting to bed a more painful experience
back in 1996 john barnes on the show
as well and as the search continues at a
collapsed miami apartment block the
letter
from this april that reveals a warning
to residents about concrete damage
getting significantly worse and asking
them to pay
towards repairs it's wednesday wednesday
the
30th of june
the italian job england to play ukraine
in the euro 2020 quarterfinals
in rome at the weekend after their
historic victory
over germany
captain kane says england is dangerous
and their competitors better watch out
as
manager southgate puts his memories of
to bed and looks to the future
these players keep writing history and
they've got the chance again
finish line but still waiting to fully
unlock we're live in blackpool to assess
the impact on businesses
as covid's support scheme prepares to
wind up
deadline day claims of a backlog of more
than 400 000 cases
as time runs out for eu citizens to
apply for the right to stay in the uk
after brexit
their necessities cubs cool off in
california as a permanent emergency is
declared in some other u.s states and
canada
over a heatwave
and nowhere near as hot here but a fine
and mostly dry day
will it last for the whole week i'll
have the details for you later
that was our cameraman waving to us from
blackpool we'll be there very shortly
before that celebrations tears of joy
and a dream that's now very much alive
england are heading to rome for the
quarterfinals of euro 2020 on saturday
they play ukraine after beating germany
for the first time
in 55 years at a major tournament
two goals to nil the captain harry kane
says
other teams watching will see that they
are dangerous
and the england manager gareth southgate
can put his painful memories
of 1996 to bed and says the side have
the chance now to keep
writing history just look at these
images how amazing
is that across the country the normal
evening rush hour
never happened as millions watched a
nervous 90 minutes at wembley
they all have watched that match last
night and definitely not be frightened
of anybody
who they might face next and certainly
not the ukraine
um what was interesting last night was
raheem sterling after the match you know
very much a sense of we're making our
own history here we're not weighed down
by the baggage of the past
and he just wasn't excited he wasn't
really getting carried away it was
almost like what is all the fuss about
we know it was a tough match but we're
through it it's just the round of 16.
this is where we should be so it is
ukraine uh
next good news uh that sterling got his
third goal fantastic news
that harry kane got his first goal and
could kick on in these championships
but watching that match uh ukraine
sweden andre
chevchenko's ukraine he's taken them the
furthest they've been
what is going to be dangerous about this
next match is
they have got nothing to lose this is
the best that ukraine have ever done
in a knockout competition so they can
play pretty
freely uh pretty dull match last night
though i have to say
and it was very much in the dying
minutes
of that match that they managed to put
the thing to bed willingly be frightened
of them
no would they be frightened of a
possible semi-final
opponents denmark or the czech republic
no
it's on to rome okay fantastic mean time
we'll go to berman see shimon's standing
by for us there this morning
uh we've seen all the flags there behind
you it must have been absolute
uproar there
yes like many parts of the country here
everyone was celebrating it's
that result last night and it seems the
entire estate has been in on it here
as it's hard to find a building that
hasn't been covered
with those england flags and obviously
all of the people on this estate will be
hoping that england
will be coming home and those hopes are
even more likely
after yesterday's historic result but
obviously
fans can't go to rome as the uk
government are asking for people that
have been
in the uk for the past eight 14 days to
self-isolate
on arrival in italy so it's likely that
fans here will be celebrating
locally for saturday okay fantastic
ladies thank you both very much
indeed uh let's bring in uh anne marie
torellian should we minister for energy
clean growth and climate change hello to
good to talk to you this morning thanks
for joining us
um italy next what's the advice the
government advised for fans who'd like
to go and watch them play
so uh uh the advice has been clearly set
out and
uh as your correspondent said honestly
it's very difficult not to smile just to
see all those wonderful flags waving
isn't it it just
makes you so proud of our team doing so
well last night
um but really the ask is to watch from
home
and to cheer on the team as loud as you
can i think the challenge is can they
hear us
from rome and i'm sure we'll take up
that opportunity to be as supportive as
we can of our amazing england team
we certainly will can i ask you about um
kovid
there's a lot of stories in the
newspapers this morning ahead of
terminus day
on the 19th of july we all hope fingers
crossed um
there has been talk from the government
about learning to live
with uh covid what does that actually
mean
to you so
uh now that we are uh you know at very
nearly
kind of fully vaccinated adult
population a phenomenal effort and you
know we've all
uh in the same way that we cheered on
our football team last night to be
honest we really
cheering on all those who've been uh
jabbing our arms to make sure that we
have the vaccination
and once uh all adults have had that
first jab and we are very nearly at all
the over 40s
uh it will mean that those most
vulnerable to very ill health
from covid are protected uh so
making sure that then we can get our
economy and our day-to-day lives
back up to a normal normal pace of life
again
is the mission uh and making sure
obviously that our health care services
are there for all the ailments
that we and our families will still
suffer from
yeah and with that in mind we've been
hearing from ian duncan smith speaking
in this morning's papers
he says there's no point in publishing
uh the figures
for covid every day we don't do it for
pneumonia we don't death figures
we don't do it for the flu so why do we
continue to do it for covid isn't it
time to stop doing that all it does is
cause alarm
well i'm sure that uh when we are able
to get to a point of
uh being back to normal um the uh
dhsc and number 10 will take a decision
on how we continue to make sure uh
people
are safe and are you able to get back to
their normal lives and i'm sure in due
course
uh that will be the case yeah but should
we continue to publish the figures i
suppose is the question
well i think for as long as uh there is
you know that
uh intense testing regime that we will
need to continue to do to be able to
manage
uh our day-to-day lives and make sure
that we are uh looking after each other
there will be uh you know that
substantial data set
to share whether it's published you know
on on the front page of a newspaper
every day or whether it's something that
those who are monitoring and making sure
that you know they're looking after us
have at their fingertips uh will no
doubt be set out by
uh department of health and due course
uh to your brief mr revellion uh uk's
commitment on coal as part of our green
uh credentials are certainly impressive
so why are we opening a new coal mine in
cumbria
so uh the announcement today is that we
have uh brought forward by a year we had
set
a 2025 uh moratorium on
coal being used on a basis called being
used to generate electricity
uh we've brought that forward by years
2024 because we've been able to
move to a much larger mix of renewables
uh then i think you know when that 2025
date was set which is fantastic news
and i think as you say is a really uh a
credit
to the shift in our in our electricity
generation
uh there is uh coal used as you say
coking coal uh
used uh in uh heavy intense industries
like steel
uh and uh others where there is still a
need because technology hasn't yet
found an alternative solution but that
coal isn't
uh burning uh for the purpose of
electricity generation and that's what
our announcement today is about
but in terms of the uh question of
whether the new uh
coking coal uh mine would be opened in
cumbria that's presently
being reviewed through the planning
system by mhclg
and i think they're due to report on
that by the end of the year but why do
we need a new coking coal mine is it
because it's in a constituency that the
conservatives won in 2017
uh no coking calls i say will continue
to to need to be used for a number of
years yet though
uh as part of the industrial industrial
cup decarbonization strategy which i
published
a couple of months ago uh we have a big
focus on helping those heavy
energy industries to find new ways to do
their business including
the steel industry who are working very
hard to look at
a number of alternate technologies but
until that point there will be a need
for taking coal so
if if we don't use uk sourced it will
have to be imported for the time being
okay um furlough scheme let me talk
about that if i may uh the uk
airline industry has called on the
treasury to extend fellow
sector workers until the end of april i
was speaking to an airline pilot just
yesterday and he said
if they came off furlough many of him
and he and his colleagues
would be losing their jobs what are we
going to do about that
so i know that uh both the aviation
minister and the treasury uh continue to
work
sector by sector and make sure that the
right balance is found and i have
no doubt that those conversations are
ongoing but i don't have any more
information okay that i can offer you at
this point
okay what can you tell us about the 5.2
million people who've applied for the
settlement scheme
tens of thousands have not got their
application processed
as yet it's being described as
potentially a new windrush
what do you want to say about that so
it's been a phenomenal scheme my mother
uh who is french but has lived in the uk
for
most of her life applied and it was a
very very efficient
uh you know process for her to do uh and
it is
a phenomenal effort that as you say 5.2
million people have applied on the
you know been through this process uh
and i
uh i'm sure that you know there will be
uh the ability to make sure that today
uh the appropriate
uh conversations are had but it is an
extraordinary effort
uh and one that's you know to the to the
fact that sometimes
uh you know government processes can be
difficult this one was a really
uh effective and slick one for those 5.2
million people to be able to value
that you know but there's 300 000
backlog
300 000 people are still waiting to be
processed are we going to start denying
them benefits
so uh if i imagine if they're in the
system that uh they will then be
processed so that you know will be a
uh i think that the deadline is today
for applications because and that's been
announced you know there's been a very
long
period for people to have time to apply
uh and that comes to an end today but i
have no doubt that if they're in the
system
uh and the processing is ongoing uh that
will
uh follow its natural course yeah but
does that mean that
they will still receive benefits while
they're being processed
so you'd uh have to ask thomas i don't
have the information on that but
uh i think the idea was always that this
is a steady
path uh and that those who are you know
here and we're applying for
uh you know the ability to to stay uh
will
therefore be you know in that process um
okay let me ask you um
about matt hancock if i may um security
experts say it would take 10 minutes
to find out who leaked the cctv uh
video of matt hancock um snogging with
his lover
because the person would have left a
digital footprint on the system
why doesn't the government know already
who did this
so uh i'm not uh privy to any of the uh
i know
uh extensive uh security uh work that
goes on
uh but i have no doubt that they will be
doing all they can to
ensure that they understand how the
problem uh in terms of that camera in
the secretary of state's office
came about and dealing uh with the
outcomes accordingly
uh okay just a final thought which i'm
sure you will be able to comment on uh
some suggestions again in the papers
this morning that mr hancock is hoping
to
return to uh frontline politics before
the end of the year would you welcome
him back
so the prime minister uh chooses his
team and
he has brought forward a fantastic new
health secretary in sanji javid
uh who brings uh an energy uh and uh
you know a passion for uh looking after
his constituents and indeed now all of
us
uh and i'm very confident that he's
going to do a great job now that he's
taken up the post
yeah that wasn't my question though my
question was well whether you would be
happy to welcome matt hancock back
before the end of the year into
frontline politics so the prime minister
will make his decisions i think matt
will
uh ask you for your opinion mr rebellion
it is something that you could comment
on because i'm sure you you know your
own mind
would you welcome him back so it's it's
not for me to comment on who the prime
minister wants to have in his cabinet
okay and i wouldn't dream of doing so
matt worked unbelievably hard last year
uh doing
almost gargantuanly impossible tasks to
make sure
uh that we got uh the health protections
that we needed and
drove forward a phenomenal vaccine
program and testing program
through you know the course of a very
very hard uh
year but i think now uh he needs time to
uh
spend with his family and have a chance
to uh get out of the limelight
maybe not with his family who knows it's
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the programme this morning thank
you
um tomorrow hi tomorrow thoughts morning
kay um i thought it was interesting what
annemarie trevelyan said about the eu
settlement scheme because the deadline
for that is tonight for um
european citizens living in britain she
said that her brother had applied and
found it very easy
i think that's the point the home office
say over five million people have
applied all you need to do is get an
app prove your residence c for five
years
and there you go but the problem is
there are still people who have no idea
that they need to apply and even if it's
only one percent we're still talking
tens or even hundreds of thousands of
people who may
28 days from now have their benefits cut
off find themselves unable to do their
job or rent a flat
at children who have been born in the uk
whose parents don't know
that because they're not british
citizens they still need to apply
on their behalf so i think there's
concern that the home office
don't just cut these people off if they
haven't applied
by the deadline because then campaigners
are saying
look as we go down the line this could
be another windrush scandal where people
are denied their rights
because they just didn't have the right
documentation or weren't aware of it
she didn't say much about furlough did
she no that is a big concern for
businesses as you were putting to her
that
the support is tapering off from today
but it's not going to be until the 19th
of july that for many industries will
know if they're going to be viable this
summer and for
travel and aviation and so on they
pretty much know it's not going to be a
viable summer
and i think that's that's something that
a lot of mps are now lobbying the
treasury about
okay for now tomorrow thanks very much
thank you also this morning as you were
hearing their
government is preparing to reduce its
contribution to the furlough
job support scheme tomorrow touching on
that as well as we've not even fully
eased restrictions yet
from tomorrow the level of furlough
payment the government contributes will
reduce to 70 this means employers
must contribute 10 percent to full load
employees wages up to
312 pounds 50 a month
and from tomorrow the stamp duty holiday
will be phased out as well buyers will
have to
pay on purchases above 250
000 pounds salient chargery joins us now
from blackpool good morning to you sally
what impact might it have there
well good morning blackpool as you know
is famous for
tourism uh holiday leisure all of these
activities and it has been one of the
worst affected areas when it came to the
furlough
in fact data from around this time last
year shows that
south blackpool had one of the highest
rates of furlough with over a third
of its workforce sent home when
businesses closed their doors and we
know of course because of lockdown
so many of these businesses haven't been
able to open for
around a year and there are currently
across the country 3.4 million people
reported to still be on furlough they're
going to see those changes that you
talked about
with employers having to pay a lot more
and what that means is if
businesses aren't doing as well then
they risk having to lay
off staff if they haven't been able to
get enough money uh through this period
to be able to pay their staff so there
is this feeling around here that you
know until things
fully reopen across the country lots of
more people will be affected
okay thank you thanks i love to see
blackpool tower behind you there sadia
thanks very much indeed for bringing
that to us
this morning reminds me of home now do
we dare to dream could football have a
chance
of finally coming home
and 25 years after it first reached the
charts football's coming home was the
song that fans
sung loud last night and the two men
behind that song were at the stadium to
watch the game as well david bedeau of
course she had a picture of himself
and frank skinner there they are
cheering at wembley captioned
it's um we all know the rest
of the words um absolutely fantastic
there's been plenty of reaction to last
night's games across
social media as you would anticipate the
prime minister boris johnson posted a
picture
on twitter of himself watching the game
writing
well done england we're all behind you
bring it home
meanwhile the uh german ambassador
andreas michaelis
wrote there you go congrats england
it's coming home there's a picture there
of the elephant as well he says wishing
you all the best
in the tournament we will have to uh he
went on to say we will have to build a
new team this great competition between
england and germany
will continued uh the the elephant had
predicted that germany would win
the england football team account
tweeted a picture of their goalkeeper
standing in the famous wembley
tumblewriting
jordan pickford that is or he was
amazing last night the england team's
official photographer
eddie keough posted this picture saying
i can't tell you how
happy i am to post this picture i've had
the privilege of being england's
photographer
for the last four years but today feels
even better
than our wonderful time in russia this
is proper
rock and roll it certainly is
and that story dominating of course the
front pages this morning as well let's
have a look
uh england's first knockout victory over
germany in 55 years is on the front
of the metro with the paper proclaiming
that the jinx
is over the sun praises the sterling
work of the footballer who scored the
first goal hailing the end of what's
described as
55 years of hurt by george we did it
says the daily mail declaring england
erupts the daily mirror says that it's
time to dream now the three lions have
broken the german hoodoo
for the daily star the big news is that
england didn't
lose to germany like emerging from a
dream into a strange
new light that's not that catchy is it
and that's the headline in the guardian
um and of course i'm sure that you'll be
uh staying with us throughout the course
of the program john barnes will be with
us here on the show
as will david seaman as well and we'll
also
look ahead to uh england facing ukraine
in the quarter-finals
of euro 2020 on saturday we'll look
ahead to that match and enjoy the
victory over germany with former
england goalkeeper as i said david
seaman at half past eight
and can england fans get to rome for
saturday's euro
2020 quarter-final against ukraine we'll
ask the italian tourist board
when we speak with them at half past
nine
packed joe mostly talking football today
of course
first time in 55 years that we've beaten
germany in a knockout
competition last time was 1966.
my goodness uh meantime other stories
making news for you
this morning it's been revealed
residents of a florida apartment
building that collapsed last week
have been sent a letter in april warning
them of serious
structural damage the letter obtained by
u.s media was sent by the president of
the apartment blocks building
association
saying that problems originally
identified in 2018
would cost more than 16 million dollars
to fix
meanwhile the search for survivors goes
on at least 12 people now known to have
died in the collapse
and officials say 149 people
are still missing officials have warned
the operation
will take some time so we're getting
all kinds of information from all these
different sources
and sometimes we only get a name or
an apartment number sometimes we don't
have both
so we're sifting through all of this
information to determine
which of these reports are in fact new
and which are duplicates and this is a
slow and methodical process so we
ask you to be patient as we continue
this audit
three in five young people say they've
received no support from their school
regards to their mental health a study
by the charity mine found nearly half of
the students said they had been
disciplined at school
for behavior relating to a mental health
issue
and there was a big shock on day two of
wimbledon as injury for serena williams
out of the tournament
she was attempting to win a record
equaling 24th grand slam title but
was forced to retire in her first round
match
as more of us go back to work your
morning commute might be changing
sooner than you think a slovakian firm
says
it's completed a half hour test flight
in their flying
car the air car as it's known claims to
transform in under three minutes with
just the press of a button
it comes just a day after the head of
hyundai in europe
said he thought that flying cars could
be used to cut congestion
and emissions by 2030.
didn't we see a flying car as early as
chitty chitty bang bang
you have to be that age i suppose let's
find out what's happening as far as the
weather's concerned it's
the sun's shining on everybody in
england today nas isn't it
uh yes sort of uh in terms of what it's
actually looking like
meteorologically currently it is
actually quite dull across
eastern areas but it should be
brightening up for most places this
afternoon
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for the vast majority of
the uk in ireland we are looking at
largely fine
and dry conditions for today with some
good spells of sunshine
slowly but surely developing this
morning though
a bit of a dull start to the day really
across parts of northern ireland
northern and eastern parts of britain as
well it's a cloudy dull start to the day
there's some drizzle around eastern
coast and hills and more persistent rain
across some parts of eastern england but
it should slowly but surely
brighten up across these areas along
with many western areas where we'll
continue with the sunshine
from this morning into this afternoon as
well so eventually most places will see
some good spells of sunshine developing
later but around eastern coastal
counties i think
along with that northerly breeze but
also some of that clouds still clinging
on it's going to feel cool and that's
going to be reflected in the
temperatures only 16 or 17
around eastern coast up to around 24
degrees
celsius locally across parts of the west
but a few showers can't be ruled out
mainly across southern ireland the south
wales and southwest england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
record temperatures continuing to hit
western canada and the united states and
for many animals
it's a struggle to keep cool this adult
black bear decided drastic action was
needed
to help her and her cubs so what did she
do
she took them to south lake tahoe beach
on sunday afternoon
despite a crowd of a goose a crowd of
onlookers
there you go everybody chilling out the
governor of washington has described the
current heat wave in the western united
states and canada
as a permanent emergency and on the more
serious side
70 people are reported to have been
killed mostly
um those that have underlying health
conditions or
are elderly will keep an eye on that for
you uh the agony
and the ecstasy we'll talk to england
and germany supporters after that
memorable match at wembley coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of action going on i'm alex
crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in
istanbul this is what
makes the job so fantastic
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west
antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
in exchange if you're recyclable to get
a tree
[Music]
hello again everybody my goodness me
what a night
it was last night uh england beat
germany the old foe for the first time
in a knockout competition
since 1966 by two goals
to nil that's how they celebrated and he
finally finally broke his duck in this
competition harry kane of course
sterling's just
walking the park for him isn't it let's
catch up with two fans who lived through
the dramatic 90 minutes of last night's
england germany game we chatted to them
yesterday they very kindly agreed
to come back today gertz mona is there
he is of course
the german fan who was monitoring events
for us
from his side and billy is with us as
well who was
with us yesterday as well i know how you
feel billy so i want to go with
first of all tell us what it was like as
a german fan
uh to be honest i thought uh the first
75 minutes
of the match were probably one of the
worst i've ever seen in my life and uh
it was just awful football really wasn't
it it was boring and uh as i said i
watched with some german and english
mates and
we were pretty shocked how cool both of
them were and then at the end of the day
england scored the goals in fair play
they won congratulations to that oh
we're looking at fans actually as uh
german fans as we're chatting to you
gertz they were absolutely devastated
you must have gone into this game
given that we haven't beaten you england
i should say haven't beaten germany
uh in a knockout competition since 1966
there must have been part of you
yesterday morning when we were chatting
thinking
this is a cakewalk for us
no as i said yesterday i always thought
it's going to be quite close
and um that's what it was for 75 minutes
but then again yeah england you know did
manage to score the goals and in all
honesty i think
personally it really sums up the last
few years of you we learned
germany has been pretty poor since the
last world cup really and you can't take
it away from him
he wants a world cup but as they say in
england good riddance
good that he goes now and they can start
a new chapter
and you know what again as i said
yesterday i'm you know also
happy for england and i hope my second
team now goes all the way and brings it
home huh
ah fantastic billy you were tweeting
in the early hours this morning how's
the head have you had any sleep
i've had i don't normally sleep actually
after games like that but i managed to
get a couple of hours to sleep actually
we were in a
bar very close to the to the stadium
until the hours the early hours of the
morning they just kept shipping the
beers in like you know so me and my
posse's puns and
and uh and soups and all that but you
know we're all there till till very
early in the morning it was a it was a
good celebration
shall we say it but we know how to
celebrate this gotta be said but
yeah what are we telling what looking at
celebrations we're chatting billy
um who were the star players for you
uh i mean listen i love sterling i think
he's you know i just think he's
brilliant you know
i think also jack greenish when he came
on he actually kind of took it up
another level
you know i know a lot of people are sort
of saying you know jack freelance don't
drop him
you know make sure that you know he's
playing all the time listen i think
we've got to trust the coaches
trust southgate heard gurts what he was
saying about terrible game for the first
75 minutes but i
slightly disagree with that because as i
said you know we have lost to germany so
many times we lose all these matches
we get to the world cup semi-final we
lose to croatia because we don't switch
it up in the second half and i think
southgate's
learned from that and i think that we
actually went into this game to play a
particular site we didn't want to let
germany score
we just did what we had to do and then
we just took it up a level in the final
was it 15 minutes or so and we just when
we took it up a level germany just
didn't know what to do we went bang bang
gold in the back of the net see you
later so uh and we're in we're in the
next round and that's what you've got to
do
you've got to remember we haven't let in
one goal okay and if you don't let it go
you're not going to lose a game
you might lose your penalties but you're
not going to lose the game and i'm very
happy with that
after like i said 40 plus years of
seeing england
not doing anything listen let's just
let's just let's just edge our way to
the semi-finals and i'm saying that
touching wood all over the place
yeah no need to show off just don't get
any let any girls in um
uh gertz is what billy is saying and you
know all due respect to the england
goalkeeper he was
magnificent yesterday
yeah absolutely i mean england again as
i said if you score the goals at the end
then you
you know fair deserved winner and that's
what england did and i really do hope
that
they can kind of take this historic
victory and write another bit of history
and finally win a title i mean i said
i've lived here 26 years and
i really really hope that can go all the
way now and it looks good at least now
you know you cry it's a beatable team
and then you know your clothes are
already stepped so
all the best to england okay billy uh
you were at wembley i think yesterday
weren't you
um i think we've got pictures of you
actually at wembley uh yesterday uh
rather and that was i'm guessing before
the game was it because you looked
pretty calm
pretty relaxed and that was obviously
when we saw one or two
goals going in lots of celebrations
around you what was it like being at
wembley
it was great i'll tell you something and
i've said to you i've been to all the
matches so far and the
the three previous matches you go there
you get your ticket you stand up there
as a bit of clapping a bit of cheering
you know but it's almost like a little
bit of a sort of kind of friendly plus i
probably think it's the best way to
describe it you know
which is a little bit of a win because
spiffer of charge has all sorts of
ridiculous money
to try and you know to go to the
previous matches and it's uh it's been a
bit it's been a bit frustrating for
england fans as well
because you know we've been shelling out
a lot of money and it's not quite be the
same but
this game we turned around to all my
mates you know dave was there you know
we had the
you know um blades come down from
sheffield as well richida and mark as
well
subs and we turned around we said this
is the first time actually feels like an
away day like when you go away
you feel the tournament vibe everyone in
that stadium was
really really up for it i was really
really pleased i was able to bring my
son
elias and the daughter bella as well who
goes to all football matches with me all
over with brentford everywhere like you
know
and she came down it's her first
european championships and the previous
one she's like
it's not that good is it you know it's
all right but this one she actually felt
the vibe behind the goal
the singing the dancing people falling
on top of you and we scored
the full monty it was absolutely
fantastic and obviously there was the
songs
that were singing you know obviously
three lions was a massive song for that
one but sweet caroline
i don't know if you got that on the tv
beforehand before the match
and afterwards when everyone the teams
are off and everything like that sweet
caroline everyone in the stadium singing
that
over and over again for like you know
stay in the stadium for about 45
minutes afterwards which is what you do
when you go to tournaments after the
game you stay in the stadium for about
an hour hour and a half singing and
dancing then just chatting to your mates
and
that vibe was wicked and it's a real
shame because i've got tickets to roam
the saturday i was going to go with a
daughter bella for that one as well we
had that all sorted out but
unfortunately due to
restrictions i've had to park that one
i'm gonna have to go to back to me
scandinavian car in town and watch the
game there with the mates instead
because unfortunately he can't make it
to
can't make it to rome you'll be able to
watch the last two games at wembley
won't you when uh
england play in the semis in the final
uh goods
absolutely what are you doing there
you're doing it now you've got that now
please yeah i'm sorry i take all of that
back we can rewind that
um gurts uh what do you think about
suggestions before i let you both go um
italians are saying you know what the
final and the semi-finals should be
played
in rome not at wembley
no no they should play to you as planned
and um as i said again
i'm now all the way for england so
played at wembley and bring it home
that's all i can say fantastic it's good
to talk to both of you guys i hope you
enjoyed the game whichever side
you were on uh come the final whistle
and thanks for taking the time to join
us this morning thank you
as well wait nice one later thank you
bye bye
bye bye uh bearing that in mind we're
actually speaking to the government
minister about
rome earlier on uh today and she was
underlining that uh
fans can't go because i think i'm right
in saying tomorrow that you have to
isolate for five days that's right the
rules in italy are that
uh people coming from britain have to
quarantine for five days so that is
too late if you're thinking of traveling
now but for
uh brits who are already in italy and
have already done their quarantine or
for the
um british expats who live in italy they
will get most of the tickets which i
think are being
put out through the embassy over there
but the fa are not selling tickets here
because
of those rules and the government
minister said the advice is watch it at
home and cheer as loud as you can
uh yeah and just a quick thought on that
she did say that she hoped that
the fans would make so much noise here
that they could be heard in italy yes
good luck with that
but she was also talking to us about the
settlement scheme now
that's right the deadline for the eu
settlement scheme is tonight at midnight
that's for all
european citizens living in the uk this
is the post brexit ender free movement
scheme for people to continue to live
and work and claim benefits
here now there have been over five
million
applications processed people who've
done done it and had their settled
status
already but the concern is there is a
backlog of 400 000
still being processed the home office
says that if you've already applied by
the deadline then you won't lose out
because they'll get to you eventually
but it may take a while
and there's also concern from
campaigners that there are people who
despite knowing that this scheme has
been
there for for over a year now don't know
they need to apply because maybe they're
an older person who's lived here for
most of their life
people who've got children born in the
uk and they don't realize that those
children aren't automatically entitled
to stay here and what these campaigners
are saying to the home office is
don't be too heavy-handed cut people's
benefits put them at risk of deportation
because there are people there may not
be it may be only a small percentage
but there are possibly tens of thousands
of people who have not applied yet
and uh there's concern that they may
lose out okay this is what she said
it is an extraordinary effort uh and
one that's you know to the to the fact
that sometimes uh you know
government processes can be difficult
this one was a really
uh effective and slick one for those 5.2
million people to be able to value sure
but the 300 000 backlog 300 000 people
are still waiting to be processed are we
going to start denying them benefits
so uh if i imagine if they're in the
system that uh they will then be
processed so that you know will be a
uh i just i think that the deadline is
today for applications because and
that's been
announced you know there's been a very
long period for people to have time to
apply
uh and that comes to an end today but i
have no doubt that if they're in the
system
uh and the processing is ongoing uh that
that will uh
follow its natural course so i think the
point is that not everyone will find it
easy also of course
british people living in europe in many
countries including france
also need to apply for residency by
today some countries have given it
automatically like spain and portugal
but not all of them and there's concern
that british people living in europe
have not applied there are over a
million british people
living in europe who need to do that
okay for now thanks a lot tamara thank
you
uh in other news the ugandan high
commissioner to the uk
are joining us shortly as his country
battles a new wave
of coronavirus that come
[Music]
the tigrayan forces have taken control
of mekale which is the
regional capital of the tigray region
the situation for the rest of the tigray
region still remains pretty much unknown
and i suspect that in the next couple of
days we will have a better sense of what
is going on
in the whole region that report that
mentioned five and a half million people
in desperate need of support we believe
is is only a tip of the iceberg and
people have needed
help desperately so for the past eight
months now
and we as unicef within our mandate we
have been providing water and sanitation
critical health support and as you know
most of the infrastructure in the region
was damaged because of the conflict
we're also ensuring that children that
suffer from severe acute malnutrition
are treated
and we admit that by december this year
about 56 000 children
will need treatment for severe acute
malnutrition that's about six times
than we normally have every single year
the world at the moment is facing many
many
crises of different nature and we as
humanitarian agencies
the un and our ngo partners have done
our best to bring
to attention to the world's attention
the severe crisis
that has happened in the tigre region
and will continue to happen i must say
at least for the foreseeable future
[Applause]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
these have been pulled up out and are
being used as missiles to hell
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney why not
meeting you fishing does have the
potential
to stymie an enormous economic deal
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment
is changing but the speed at which those
changes are happening
[Music]
[Applause]
done
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
the vast majority of the uk and island
will be mainly dry and sunny today
although it will be cloudy at first in
the east with drizzle along eastern
coasts
as well as some more widespread rain
over eastern england but this afternoon
the east should mostly see sunny spells
developing along with the rest of
britain island and northern ireland
polar levels will be high for most
places but very high for western england
however levels will be moderate across
wales and the northern isles of scotland
we are currently in the peak of the
grass pollen season and fungal spores
are at a medium risk there is also
plenty of weed pollen about mainly
nettle
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
indeed sir and for you uh hay fever
sufferers everywhere i hear you are here
it's nearly over now from today the
government is relaxing some of the covet
travel restrictions but only for a
handful of
places here we go spain's baleric
islands madeira and malta have been
added to the uk's green travel list
which means
that a negative kovit-19 test is
required
before and after travelling
but spain's government has now said that
britain's arriving in mallorca ibiza and
other baleric islands will have to
present a negative chess result
on arrival or prove that they are fully
vaccinated from today the portuguese
island of madeira has moved to the green
list for those entering
england so only a negative test from
england
i should say so only a negative test is
needed and that's the same for malta now
which is also on the uk's green list but
malta's government is only allowing
double vaccinated brits
into the country you have to be fully
vaccinated
the other end of the scale uganda has
moved on to the uk's red list
after the country saw a significant rise
in coronavirus
cases to talk about that in more detail
uganda's high commissioner to the uk
and ireland his excellency julius peter
moto
is with us now your excellency thank you
for joining us on the program
this morning tell me your thoughts about
uganda being added to the red list
good morning kay and uh good morning to
all our listeners
government of uganda received a
notification that
we shall be put on a red list of our
countries due to coronavirus effective
tonight
this was announced and we received
official communication
i convey my deepest condolences to
everyone in the uk who have lost dear
ones
as this as you know this kobe 19 has
caused a lot of pain and a lot of people
have died
our sympathies are with the families
that have suffered
recently uganda experienced experienced
deep rise in covet 19 cases
attributed to a variant called
delta variant listeners
would note that by the end of
the year 2020
there were 35 000 cumulative cases of
covered in uganda
as of close business yesterday they were
close to
77 000
and by middle of march
the graph actually had flattened there
were no deaths
attributed to kobe 19 actually for a
period of two weeks
there were no deaths uganda won the war
against kobe 19. however
rising from middle of may up to
yesterday
the total number of cases had been 1735
recorded this has been quite high
the cumulative cases to date is 79 000
persons
total recovery is 52 000 persons
active cases in our health facilities
about 1180 persons
and the total deaths recorded since
march
2020 had been 989 persons
so you see it's a big problem we had
addressed the problem
but from mid-may the cases started
rising again
however the government of uganda has put
in place
measures government of uganda locked
down the country on the 19th of june
and is going to last for 20 40 42 days
we stopped public transportation
schools were closed mass gatherings were
prohibited
and passengers coming from high-risk
countries
were restricted to enter uganda
government of uganda had continued to
undertake
vaccination to date
almost 1 million people have been
vaccinated
and about 1.4 million people have been
tested
so the implication for
this lockdown on our bilateral
relationship
it's regrettable and we believe it's a
temporary
measure although free travels between
uganda and uk
is going to be affected businesses will
be affected
including trade and tourism right now
is only the uk nationals that can travel
freely
from uganda to uk those with resident
status
including diplomats and students with a
student's visa uganda will still allow
the uk nationals and travelers
from the uk to enter uganda provided
they present
negative pcr orbit 19 tests
test flight certificate taken within 72
hours
before flight okay we are confident
that these measures once we have address
all our problems uh we are going to
leave the country and
we will be put back to win or humble
list very soon
okay your excellency thank you for
taking the time to explain that to our
viewers
uh this morning i'm sure they appreciate
that thank you very much
uganda going on to the red list as
some of the balearic islands and indeed
madeira and malta go on to the
green list have a quick look at what
happened last night
as if you needed to be reminded they
went mad
down in south london when england
scored that goal that's what happened
there we go
absolutely amazing uh scored twice of
course
didn't we sun shining uh honours um
today let's hope so
here is good morning yep there will be
some sunshine eventually
this afternoon bit of a dull start this
morning for sunday
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning eventually most of the uk
and ireland
will see sunshine for this afternoon
after a rather dull start around some
northern and eastern areas this morning
where it's
rather cloudy there's patchy light rain
and drizzle also some more persistent
rain around eastern parts of england but
eventually as i said it brightens up
eastern coastal air is staying cool but
warm in the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways